berlin schöneberg am freitagmorgen mit
einem großaufgebot sich hat die polizei
die umgebung rund um den zwölf apostel
friedhof hier soll am vormittag die
beerdigung der mutter von clan chef
arafat abou chaker stattfinden
gut 200 beamte sind dazu vor ort sie
haben kontrollpunkte für die trauergäste
eingerichtet sind mit zivilen fahndern
unterwegs und sorgen für die
durchsetzung der hygienemaßnahmen ab 10
uhr treffen die ersten gäste ein die
meisten in kleinen gruppen am ende sind
es laut polizeiaussagen über 250 sie
alle müssen sich in von der polizei
ausgelegten listen eintragen
arafat abou chaker hatte schon vor der
beerdigung deutlich gemacht was er von
den trauergästen erwartet pünktlichkeit
und höflichen umgang miteinander
außerdem wies er auf die masten pflicht
hin bild reporter peter heß nun live
zugeschaltet hat die beerdigung
beobachtet er wie lief das ganze heute
ab es ließ entsprechend der situation
sehr ruhig ab sehr gediegen sehr
respektvoll heute morgen wie wir es
gerade gehört haben in der maz sind die
ersten trauergäste um 11 uhr vor 11 uhr
eingetroffen hinter mir sieht man auch
dass die beerdigung jetzt zu ende
gegangen ist
das hat einen folgenden grund zuerst
sind die männer auf den friedhof
geleitet worden um eben abschied von
massimo busacca zu nehmen und es gibt
eine zweite gruppe nachher das sind dann
die frauen und der polizeischutz der
polizeieinsatz hat natürlich einen
hintergrund und die möchte ich eben
erfahren neben mir steht die sprecherin
der berliner polizei anja reschke
frau dr können sie uns gott sagen warum
200 polizisten eine beerdigung schützen
müssen
wir sind mit gut 200 einsatzkräften hier
vor ort nicht um die beerdigung zu
schützen aber um zu gewährleisten dass
bei einer so hohen teilnehmerzahl der
infektionsschutz gewährleistet wird
werden kann und andererseits das
natürlich bei den vielen gästen die
erwartet wurden die den verkehrsfluss
nicht mehr als notwendig beeinträchtigt
wird welche maßnahmen haben sie denn
getroffen die person mussten in gruppen
hier eingehen auf den friedhof was wurde
da gemacht
wir haben dafür sorge getragen dass der
andrang hier an der pforte zum friedhof
nicht so groß ist dass die menschen
nicht mehr den notwendigen
mindestabstand einhalten können denn
hier an der pforte war es wichtig dass
sich jeder teilnehmer und auch später
jede teilnehmerinnen dieser trauerfeier
in die listen ein trägt die daten
erfassen dass man später in einem
positiven fall dann auch kontakt mit den
einzelnen teilnehmern und
teilnehmerinnen aufnehmen kann
wir sind teilweise clan-mitglieder
aufgetaucht zur beerdigung hat es auch
was damit zu tun dass so eine art
observationsmaßnahmen die gewährleistung
des infektionsschutz und dann die
verkehrslenkung und leitung dass es für
die anderen verkehrsteilnehmenden keine
behinderungen gibt vielen dank frau
dürfte dankeschön nele ja wir haben das
gehört also es ist sehr ruhig abgelaufen
der sohn arafat abou chaker ja nochmal
die trauergäste gebeten sich wirklich an
diese hygiene regeln zu halten
natürlich sind auch beamte zivilbeamte
hier im einsatz gewesen die auch
natürlich observiert haben weil es
handelt sich hier um einen berliner
grosz klar da ist natürlich sind auch
teile der organisierten kriminalität
gewesen insofern spielt das natürlich
eine sehr interessante rolle
im vorfeld muss man sagen dass eben auch
der prozess am montag 4
busacca söhne angeklagt sind im prozess
gegen bushido wegen räuberischer
erpressung
dass der prozess unterbrochen worden ist
deswegen und die mutter nahm mir ist ja
auch an corona verstorben
der nacht zu mittwoch und in neukölln
hat am mittwoch eine trauerfeier mit
etwa 100 personen stattgefunden
dort haben die soeben abschied genommen
was eben aus klaren sicht relativ
interessant ist es ein hohes mitglied
ein führender kopf des renault clans ist
sehr spät hier auch zur beerdigung
erschien nämlich um zwanzig nach elf
alleine und in begleitung mit seinem
sohn das war im prinzip eine rück besuch
seine mutter ist von israel im april
verstorben dauert ist auch eben arafat
abou chaker erschien also hier hat man
sich dann eben den respekt unter den
clan mitgliedern bezeugt und es ist
alles sehr friedlich abgelaufen und
gleiche kommen eben die frauen auf dem
friedhof in dank peter held für diese
eindrücke von der beerdigung mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren